how you age is a choice call the even
call the Charlottetown you may call the
salesperson because if you don't see the
world is insane you're declaring your
own insanity you think world peace like
a perfect world peace as possible so if
there's one thing you'll notice with
guests on value taming there's variety
of guests on different topics and that's
intentional because I like to talk about
varieties of topics this is what we call
it value tainment
value we bring a lot of value but
there's a part of it that's also
entertainment as well today I'm sitting
with somebody who has written 88 books
many of you guys are planning on writing
a book he's written 88 books of which 24
are New York Times bestsellers let me
say that one more time 24 are New York
Times bestsellers I think one of them
that his second book that did very well
was quantum healing we'll get into that
a little bit another one was called the
seven spiritual laws of success and in
his latest book the healing self that
we'll cover as well Time magazine in
June of 1999 called him one of the top
100 heroes of the past century and with
that being said today we have a guest
Deepak Chopra thank you for joining LT
Patrick it's great to have you here with
us and if we're gonna see meat any worse
san diego's obviously one of the finest
cities in America I called it earlier
the best-kept secret I think more people
are realized realize it's not a secret
anymore but it's good to be here with
you so thank you I read about you and
you're obviously to some you have a very
loyal following Mario and I were in
Hawaii a few months ago I think I was in
Hawaii with an insurance company a few
months ago and I saw 500 people outside
do you know they're doing yoga and
they're just like I'm like what is going
on here and everybody was so calm and
you know I'm not like always going and
you know why always kind of brings it I
said why are you guys so calm what's
going on Oh
Deepak Chopra he is here oh my gosh you
don't do you know who he is do you
studies I said of course I know the name
but you're following swears by you and
what you talk about and teach them but
before we get into that part you
obviously come from India why don't we
talk about before Deepak became Deepak
who was Deepak in India when your father
was a cardiologist and you decided to
come to the states I think in 1972 study
Western medicine talk about that
transition before you became who you are
today
well I grew up in India I went to an
Irish Christian missionary school then
went to medical school and I qualified
as a doctor and I came to the United
States to do my internship and then
residency and then fellowship I got
certified board-certified in internal
medicine endocrinology all in Boston got
I was teaching at Tufts University bu
and also for a short period at Harvard I
trained in neuro chemistry which is
basically neurotransmitters in the brain
and I realized that whatever happens in
our mind or consciousness translates
into biochemistry in our brain and
ultimately has an effect on our body
so I basically wrote earlier books
exploring the mind-body connection later
I realized that even that was inaccurate
body mind er a single experience and
what we call consciousness body mind is
one entity just like space-time is one
entity or mass energy is one entity wave
particles are one entity body mind is
one entity your whole body is also your
subconscious mind the brain of course
orchestrates mind - usually in English
with an Indian accent using English word
in Indian it with English accent so what
what made you want to get into this was
it your you know kind of seeing what
your father was doing and kind of wanted
to follow in that direction with
medicine because you kind of went
against what he was a cardiologist right
what got you so interested in this topic
well I realized from my own clinical
experience that you could have two
patients who had the same illness saw
the same doctor got the same treatment
but could have different outcomes you
know one could recover the other could
die so I realized that you
beings were more than molecules human
beings have personal relationships they
engage in social interactions they think
they feel they love they get upset they
get angry they get jealous
we are very complex creatures and if you
only look at the physical mechanisms of
disease you might be lucky and the
person might recover but you might not
have that recovery as well so everything
from daily experiences like eating
breathing digestion metabolism
elimination how we experience the world
or the five senses our thoughts our
feelings our imagination creativity
fears or anxieties our aspirations our
emotions all of that influences what's
happening in the biology so I realized
that medicine as we practiced it is very
effective for acute illness so we we or
we India we here in western West yeah
it's very effective when you have
somebody who has an acute illness so if
you have pneumonia
we need an antibiotic you break a leg
you need to see an orthopedic surgeon
you have appendicitis you need surgery
etc but when we look at chronic illness
you know the vast majority of chronic
illnesses including cancer heart disease
autoimmune disease frequent infections
degenerative disorders diabetes type 2
obesity metabolic syndrome which is most
of illness in our society when you look
at that it's related to lifestyle 95% of
illness is not genetically mediated only
5% of disease related gene mutations are
fully penetrant which means the
predictor disease ninety-five percent
when you look at the human body you'll
find there's low-grade inflammation
and people don't even know that and it's
related to stress is related to lack of
sleep it's related to emotional distress
it's related to poor diet is related to
lack of exercise it's related to so many
factors that no pharmaceutical agent is
going to have you say 95 percent of it
that's what we're learning maybe even
more only 5% of gene mutations that
cause disease a mutation is a genetic
mistake so you know if somebody has a
baraka gene like Angelina Jolie had
that's a fully penetrant gene and you
can't prevent the breast cancer from
happening so people usually do a
preventive mastectomy but you know
that's less than 5% of all illness and
you've said in a past before and I read
about this the fact that you said to age
is a decision you choose to age you
don't have to age I think something and
maybe I'm saying how you age how you age
as a choice so you know I'm 71 and a
half okay right now but biologically I
feel like I'm thirty-five or less you
feel thirty-five or less yes then I have
the mental and physical capacity of
somebody like that be a little more
specific what do you mean you feel like
you're 35 or less if you measure my
blood pressure by heart rate my immune
system hormone levels my biological age
would be much less less than my
chronological age so you know when you
look at aging there's biological age in
which you can measure through
cholesterol HDL ratios blood pressure
immune function hormones fat content
skin thickness bone density aerobic
capacity sugar metabolism these are the
ways you measure biological age then
there's chronological age the date you
were born
that's your chronological and my
chronological age is 71 plus but
biologically I'm not there yet okay and
then there's psychological age which
means how do you feel do you feel young
do you feel old etc so aging is a very
complex phenomenon
and in humans it's not something that's
so fixed in the last century for example
only a hundred years ago the average
lifespan of a human being in this
country was 49 years 100 years ago in
yeah but the average turn immediately of
course they're always sure to live long
today the fastest growing segment of the
American populations over the age of 90
and close to hundred that means the rate
of growth of the population the average
rate of growth is much bigger as I said
the fastest growing segment of the
American population is over the age of
90 as a Welsh means a kid born today is
probably gonna live 220 years old let's
see that's it well a lot of people are
predicting right yes so let me let me
ask you this let me ask you is that a
test to a testament to how much medicine
has advanced over the years because
outside of that what else would we give
credit to well it's very interesting
when you really look at the credit it is
improved nutrition and sanitation so
people were dying of malnutrition which
made them more susceptible to infections
and other disorders and then sanitation
and vaccinations that's how we it's not
antibiotics let's say it's not
pharmaceuticals it's still conditions of
living no better hygiene better
nutrition
but now the increment to that is
understanding what causes accelerated
aging lack of sleep stress unhealthy
emotions like hostility and anger and
resentments and guilt and shame and
depression and anxiety lack of mind-body
coordination that's where the yoga and
the breathing techniques come in poor
nutrition right now most of our food
that comes
to us at home is manufactured refined
processed contains chemicals contains
antibiotics contains steroids because
animals are fed that and even you know
there are pesticides in the ground with
short roll iam products how does that
caused accelerated aging it causes
inflammation of something called the
microbiome which is the genes that are
in your gut which are microbial genes so
99% of the genetic information in your
body right now
is not human you only have 1% of the
genes in your body or from your parents
99% of the genes in your body right now
I'm microbial you're a few human immune
come like an x-man you're a few human
cells hanging on to a bacterial column
so when you put food in your mouth the
first thing that they in count the food
encounters is these bacterial genes and
if your food is inflamed then the
bacterial genes get inflamed causes
inflammation in the body get metabolites
that are called cytokines there's lots
of complexity between the human genome
the microbiome and lifestyle but knowing
this we can extend on it so so ok so
let's go back to that there 100 years
ago 1918 give or take we're living up to
49 today it's 90 a newborn today could
live on bread at Hunter ten years old
hundred twenty years old if a kid is
born today on average they're just
saying based on blood that's the expect
expectation no one's gonna know
obviously we have to wait 120 years if
it's good trend is in that that's right
so I see couple different things and I
want to hear your take on this one does
that mean we are in less stress today
and the world population is doing more
yoga are we more calm today that's why
we're living up to 90 years old
No or is it it then why are we living
longer today than 100 years ago I said
the average increase in lifespan is
because of what I told you better
conditions of living people used to have
heat stroke no there's air conditioning
got it so yes technology may be added
with lifestyle plus advanced medicine
let me put all those together that's
okay
fair enough okay so that's good to know
if we're go in that direction and
obviously nowadays but you know did this
is also another issue that's arising as
a result of that if a person is 85 years
old there's a very high likelihood of
them having Alzheimers and again when
you look at the genes of Alzheimer's or
dementia they're only four or five
percent that predict that the rest are
again related to lifestyle so if
somebody has lack of sleep for example
which has been underestimated is the
number one predictor of premature death
from cardiovascular illness but also
associated with Alzheimer's so there's I
mean we're getting more sleep today than
we did 100 years ago not everybody knows
it so it's not you know you are trying
to point out one thing I'm not trying to
point it out whatever what I'm trying to
say what those who have good sleep those
who manage stress those who have a
healthy diet those who have better
nutrition those who have better
conditions of living they have a better
chance of living longer and healthier
and this does not replace technology of
medicine for acute illness okay so you I
think you also said something in that
same article the fact that you think a
man can take care of themselves in a way
that maybe they'll live forever maybe
there was not live forever was a live
for a long time so can man live 200
years a lot of people are saying that
humans can but right now there's no
scientific basis for that what do you
think at the moment I can't say that
because you know we have a genetic clock
that's programmed for death so even if
you didn't get heart disease or diabetes
or whatever you know cancer the genetic
clock the cells multiply at a certain
rate after a certain amount of time they
stop and this is controlled by a genes
so this is nature's way of keeping life
fresh so it do
you think we're gonna get to a point
where you know we're gonna come up with
such a ridiculous scientific someone's
gonna come out with a pill that you're
gonna live forever do you think we're
ever gonna get to that point by Buddha
mercy it's impossible but at the moment
there's no scientist so possibility but
a possibility I would have predicted
even two hundred years ago that we'd be
flying these big ships they had well
airplanes heavier than you know tons of
so many times heavier than the
atmosphere or Internet people would you
want to live forever would would no I
think you're living forever is a
guarantee for eternal senility eternal
senility break it down for a sixth
grader watching this we would be doomed
to eternal senility that is a way of
keeping life fresh in fact we die every
day and we are born anew every day you
know the cells in your body they your
stomach cells die every five days and
then you have new ones your skin cells
die once a month your liver
recycles every six weeks your skeleton
recycles every three months Nature has a
way of recycling everything whether it's
matter energy or molecules or
consciousness what is what is our
mankind's infatuation
maybe not yours with wanting to live for
very long time even some wanted to live
forever you know you see movies that
they come out and they say oh my gosh
you know we finally figured out the
formula for living forever
what is our infatuation wanted to live
for so long is it the fact that our
number one fear in life is death the
number one fear of life is death and yet
death is universal so I usually say
since death is universal and nobody's
escaped it don't take it personally so
I'm in the life insurance business and
we see what happens with because life
insurance is linked to how many years
the average life expectancy of males and
a female that's right so that's how we
sell insurance
is any 80s yes and life in cost of life
insurance
today's the cheapest it's ever been you
people think inflation goes higher it's
cheaper than it's ever been why because
it's a mathematical formula they man
used to live to 69 now it's 75 now it's
79 it has to be cheaper so it seems
really longer in women than in women
live four years longer than they do on
average three to four years longer
that's the four years of celebration you
know it's like the thing you know I'm
free you know but finally have the time
to go out there and hang out with my
friends but you know it go going back to
that topic when you're talking about
death and and and you know we're
eventually going to die and actually you
know this may be too much for your
audience the real you is not subject to
birth and death what dies is an
experience that we call the body so
that's happening all the time the body
you had as a baby is dead now the body
had as a toddler is dead the body you
had as a teenager is that in fact the
body had to years ago is not the body
you have right now every single 98
percent of the molecules that you have
in the body are not the same so birth
and that are happening all the time if
you realize from a spiritual point of
view which maybe your audience may or
may not be interested in you are not the
body
you are the consciousness in which the
body is having and is in which the body
is an experienced a park who is your
audience who is your audience my show
your audience and and I can put a number
to your audience but I want to see what
is the ideal follower audience of Deepak
look like anyone who is interested in
self awareness and knowing who they are
would you put a number to it or no I
mean I have 15 million people on social
media so that's the audience right now
ingrain I think you're tapping into an
audience that no one else is reaching
for in the self-help realm I really
really well itself up it's self
awareness self awareness you know some
call it self help some call a personal
development some call it you know
personal growth the audience you're
tapping into is a very different
audience than everybody else's there's
not a lot of people that are tapping
into the other slowly slowly waking up
from the hypnosis of social conditioning
yes I'll give you an idea so when I when
I've seen the the audiences you have
I'll see a 40s a eighty percent of them
were women that are coming to your
audience there's not a lot of people
that are going after that audience and
it just seems like you were not going I
know you're not you've attracted that
audience it's not like you're gone after
then let's try to market ourselves to
this you've attracted a why do you think
that audience is turned on to your
approach because I look at you you know
I look at some other personalities some
personalities are very high strong right
and you're just so intense and you know
you know success and go do this and go
do that I may fall into that myself
you're very calm easygoing relaxed you
know you every daughter would love to
have a father like you you know he's so
loving he's so caring he's so easygoing
you think that's what it is on on why
they're so turned on to your energy you
may be I don't try to guess yeah so I'm
a bi outside is my Indian accent yeah
it's probably what it is we were
recently in Mumbai we were nearby and we
went to the the place where Gandhi lived
for I think like 13 years he lived in
this one place for 13 years and then we
went to the slums who went to few other
plot was speaking at an IIT event with
the the chairman of
Bank of India SBI I don't that the I
think about shaadi I think that's her
name and we had a very good time being
there but the energy and the spirit a
lot in that community was very calm
easygoing and I don't know if it's a
cultural thing I once read somewhere
that said it was a cultural thing it's
being destroyed now with all the stress
and relentless ambition of the new
generation that wants to be like
everybody in the US what do you think
about that what do you think about the
relentless ambition it does it the way
you said it you're not you're not -
doesn't sound like you're too fond of it
I think there's a better way to achieve
success you know the success if it costs
so much and you end up having a heart
attack and then what's the point or you
get up get sick what's the point you age
prematurely or you die what's the point
in my view success should come
effortlessly it has comfort Leslie to me
you know when you know what your purpose
in life is when you know what you want
when you have goals that are worthy so I
define success as the progressive
realization of worthy goals combined
with the ability to love have compassion
but most importantly to not be
overshadowed by the melodrama that's
around you there's too much melodrama
you know whether it's fake news or real
news it's all melodrama
the more drama there is the better it
sells so you consume any content
yourself I look out of curiosity as you
watch of the world yeah so you do follow
it do you have like a you follow CNN or
MSNBC but just to follow how insane the
world is and that right now what we call
society global society I think
a lunatic asylum I picked up my
visitor's badge so I watch the show but
I don't get involved in it so let's
transition a topics and let's go into
maybe something else for me you know
when I was by the way if you don't see
the world is insane you're declaring
your own insanity
I mean this world has you know let's put
it all together climate change war
terrorism extinction of species
destruction of ecosystem poisoned the
food chain atom bombs nuclear weapons
mechanized debt it's insanity do you
think that's just the fact that we've
become better marketers do you think
that that's always been around always
been around but we have modern
capacities and tribal minds and this
combination will lead to our extinction
this combination will lead to our
extinction but we've done it multiple
times before it's not like we've never
done it before we didn't have this kind
of capacity that we have today whether
its technological or its mechanised debt
or bombs so are you thinking that's the
direction we're going unless we all wake
up and realize that you know we are so
interconnected and so interdependent so
you think that is possible do you think
world peace like a perfect world peace
is possible I think it will require
radical personal transformation because
there's no social transformation in the
absence of personal transformation the
society is made of people so if there's
a critical mass of people going in the
direction of peace harmony love social
justice economic justice sustainability
then yes it's possible you really think
it's possible well for lack of a better
thing to do that's my goal to reach a
critical mass of people so we can have a
more peaceful just sustainable healthier
and joyful world it that may not work
but then at least don't you think don't
you think partly why maybe what you talk
about works is because you have an
opposition and if you didn't have an
opposition you wouldn't be Deepak Chopra
today meaning yes or no question I'm
asking you explicitly I do it
already means our implicit allies you
have 15 million people that following on
social media because you have you know
50 hundred million people that disagree
with you think about that yeah we've
been called the you've been called the
Charlottetown you've been called a
salesperson because and you you accept
you don't accept you don't uh you don't
use to take it personally but it doesn't
bother you today when they're saying
that because you also have a massive
loyal following this is this is the
point I'm trying to make I think a lot
of times when when the conversation
happens about world peace but by the way
we're with Arianna Huffington and she
talks about sleep she wrote a book
called sleep your way to the top you
know good book and she even made it bed
maladies for iPhones I don't know if
you've seen her new bed she's made for
phones and she puts her phones to sleep
on this bed I got one of them in my
house and it just sits there my phone
still haven't slept in that bed yeah
it's okay but she has all this stuff
that she does I think there's an
audience that I know this is gonna sound
strange but I think somehow if there was
no evil there would not be any good to
recognize and appreciate but all
experiences by contrast so there's no up
without it down there's no pleasure
without pain there's no joy without
suffering there's no heart without cold
etc so experiences by contrast yes and
you know adversaries keep each other
going like Trump and what's his name Kim
Jung or Putin the guy kept going so as
I've said the explicit enemies are
implicit allies got it just maybe today
because you know we forget the fact that
there is there is a group of people in
the world that have access to a button
that if they press this button you know
we got 13,000 nuclear bombs around the
world give or take that number could be
less it could be yeah but somebody some
kid in East Europe in some remote
village could use their handheld phone
yeah and interfere with a traffic
signals poison the food chain you want
me to give you ideas I shouldn't because
it's it's going to be much easier than
depending on President or someone like
that you know look at what you know if
the hacking story is true American
democracy was interfered by some guys
sitting in remote access with little
device do you know who John McAfee is
the founder of McAfee Antivirus I don't
know if you know who he is you probably
have seen McAfee Antivirus on your
computer he's a founder of it very
strange guy if you don't study what he's
done because it'll it'll it'll get you
to want world peace even more if you
actually see what he's done what he
would eat was I'm not attached to a
piece if we get extinct then
nature will have decided itself that the
human species is an interesting
experiment that I see it more like that
as well no but one of the things he said
is he said I think the biggest thing in
the world today to worry about isn't a
nuclear war he said it's a cyber war
yeah he said you know what you've really
lost where you think yeah it's it's it's
a it's a twenty year yeah it's so much
easier and way more effective and it
could hurt the way more people if a guy
know how to get into banks and you know
electricity and all the sudden appear
with pacemakers ventilators poison the
food chain like interfere with air
traffic signals let's not talk yeah so
it sounds like you would be the perfect
guy for that if you wanted to go evil
the guy to do that so so you know years
ago for me I was an atheist for big part
of my life I lived in Iran and ten years
in Iran when the war happened between
Iran and Iraq I lived in Tehran and we
got bombed many many times it was
terrible I couldn't believe in God we'd
go to church and I'd get kicked out of
Bible study all the time because I would
say I don't believe God exists there's a
God exists why did 78 people die
yesterday
why did Saddam keep you know sending
planes over the border and we hear this
Alamut Hermes Tara Joe Tara Joanie would
hear that it's just everybody would get
scared you'd run to the basement you'd
hide under the stairs I said there's
nobody God exists I go into the army I
have my expect my own experience at an
army boot camp when somebody invited me
to get away from boot camp for two it is
because my PT score was high and then I
met a man and from their relationship
started one day for me I became curious
I studied Scientology I wanted to know
everything
Mormonism Christianity Judaism I just
started consuming all this content and
that went for about two year period I
would go to Scientology centers that go
to healthiest churches that go to every
single thing I could I was so obsessed
about wanted to figure out that part of
my life because for me this is for me
and I want to ask you this because you
wrote a book about this
he said one of them that did very very
well you'd the seven seven spiritual
laws of success I kind of want you to
talk about the seven spiritual laws the
moment I was connected spiritually for
myself that made sense to me nothing
could get in my way and and the pressure
of wanting to do it for somebody else
was gone the pressure was more for me to
do it because I was serving a higher
purpose
to you when you wrote the book seven
spiritual laws of success can you can
you talk a little bit about those seven
spiritual laws of success to you yeah I
wrote the book looking at just how
phenomena in nature occur in nature you
see effortless spontaneity you know bird
is not trying to fly it just lies right
children learn to walk and speak
effortlessly seed sprout into flowers
and in every seat there's the promise of
thousands of forests so there's
something called spontaneous creativity
in nature spontaneous and our biology is
an example of that it's spontaneously
self-regulating self-organizing
self-healing left alone your body
functions with effortless ease so the
seven spiritual laws was how does
consciousness transform itself into
experience by consciousness I mean that
part of our being in which we are having
any experience right now we're having an
experience the people who are watching
us are having an experience where is
that experience happening now you know
if you go to a neuroscientist they might
say it's happening in the brain but know
what's happening in the brain our neural
correlates of experience chemical
electrochemical activity but you're not
experiencing electrochemical activity
you will experience in colors shapes
sounds textures
you're experiencing thoughts emotions
this in science today is called the hard
problem of consciousness how do atoms
and molecules produce thought and
feeling and emotion and intention and
inspiration and longing and aspiration
and even these questions is there a god
etcetera
so the reason why people can't find an
explanation for consciousness is that
there's no biological explanation for
consciousness you ask anyone
there's nobody knows there's no
biological explanation for existence
there's no biological explanation for
awareness of existence not only we know
that this exists we also know that we
know that it exists in the absence of
consciousness even if it existed we
would know right so in many of the great
spiritual traditions they don't even use
the word God they use the word
consciousness as the ultimate basis of
all equations which one who uses that we
don't Buddhism okay got any of those
Eastern philosophical systems yes they
don't use the word God they used the
word consciousness and consciousness is
that in which we have mental and
perceptual experience so if I asked you
what's this let me ask you about this
what is this this these little things
all right what's this
cotton it's a sweater okay what's this
your hand okay now if you were a baby
you wouldn't have these concepts right
all you would see is colors shapes
smells gestures and you would be bathed
in this experience that we call
perception colors the rest is a human
construct sofa is a human construct for
a shape or color a texture as well this
is how we created human civilization we
gave names to experiences in
consciousness and then we objectified
that in the notion of a physical world
what's your point with this there is no
such thing there's
the consciousness transforming itself
into experience once you understand the
mechanism then you'll understand what
the seven spiritual laws is
consciousness is field of infinite
potential it moves through giving and
receiving I hate to use the word Karma
because all people have strange ideas
about it but every action creates a
response and you can choose your actions
the world functions with least effort
intention organizes its own fulfillment
detachment is the key to getting
anything you want and if you don't have
a purpose in life then your life is
meaningless so these are the seven
spiritual laws talk about detachment we
were with Jacque or yesterday it's
amazing that we're sitting with Jacque
Jacque I don't know if you know who Jaco
willing kids Jaco was a 20 year Navy
SEAL he was a commander of one of the
units of maybe SEAL Team three and he
talked about in his book called extreme
ownership he talked a lot about detached
detaching yourself so what does
detaching yourself mean to you the
attachment simply means it's impossible
to grasp any experience experiences
ungraspable so what happened to your
childhood it's over right what happened
to last night it's over what happened to
five minutes ago it's over what happens
to these words by the time you hear them
it's over so every experience you have
is transient you can't hold on to it
just like you can't hold on to your
breath if you do you'll suffocate
so detachment means recognizing that
grasping at the ungraspable is
impossible change is the only non change
and therefore the moment you attach
yourself to the experience you're
attaching yourself to a ghost it doesn't
exist so if you want to bridge open the
ungraspable is impossible yeah
why because you can't grasp an
experience you know the philosopher
Wittgenstein the German philosophy he
said our life is a dream we are asleep
but once in a while we wake up enough to
know we are dreaming so what do we know
wake up to we wake up to the
consciousness the spirit in which the
dream is happening this right now is a
lucid dream in a vivid now so in other
words we're on shrooms right now is what
you're saying
naturally we are on we're experiencing
of virtual reality and now we are
extending that to augmented reality and
artificial intelligence and almost got
to you
when you think about god who has got to
you I would say we're all God in drag
you're the divine intelligence that has
assumed this form what do you pray for
because you meditate obviously you're
big man you're built on yoga generation
is not prayer meditation is getting rid
or going beyond all thought all
experience all perception into the
stillness which is the source of all
experience do you pray not really
I ask myself questions like Who am I
what do I want what's my purpose what am
i grateful for these are spiritual
questions and then if you live the
questions life has a strange way of
moving you into the answers so when you
were asking the question did you ever
pursue the question of who is God where
it pulled you to getting the answer for
that if you can imagine God if you can
think about God if you can conceptualize
God it's not God if God exists as
infinite being then God is beyond
imagination our conceptualization of
course you can write infinity in a
mathematical formula and by the way this
is what now all the physicists do they
include infinity in all their
calculations but you can't grasp
infinity right so God is the
immeasurable potential for all
experiences and all knowing
in every living species your experience
is a human experience what does the
world look like to a butterfly
what does the world look like to a snake
that senses infrared
what does it look like to a bat that
senses echo of ultrasound see the
experience is so complex and
unexplainable the source of that
experience is an infinite consciousness
cannot be conceptualized the only thing
you can do is be humbled by the
magnificence of existence and have
reverence for existence and that's a
holy experience so you know in every
religion by the way is founded on a
religious experience and what was the
experience transcendence the emergence
of love compassion joy equanimity the
desire for truth goodness beauty and
harmony and the loss of the fear of
death because death happens to your body
and your mind but not to the
consciousness in which body and mind are
an experience so what do you believe
happens when we die what happens to us
what happens to the space in this room
if this house is destroyed gone the
space cannot be destroyed or created
this space the space in this room space
but this is right it's gone the shape
that you give this is gone so nothing
happens to you when you die elaborate
what it would mean by that this body
mind system is what consciousness has
chosen to have a communication with that
body mind system the consciousness in
which this experience is happening is
not in time okay so what's the most
common word that you use in any language
love no I I was a baby I had Chinese
food I went to
movies I am in love by engaging in the
stock market so I is the common factor
in every changing experience the
experience is changing including the
experience of your body the experience
of that which you call the mind and the
experience of that which you call the
world it's always changing but I is
constant okay and that I is not in time
and that I is not a person the person
itself is a process of that time are you
understand I'm understand is one you
know what is I I is a timeless awareness
in which we have infinite experiences
it's our destiny to play an infinity of
roles I'm playing the role of this guide
that you're interviewing now but I also
play the role of a doctor son father etc
etc but I'm not the roles I'm playing I
is the spirit the consciousness in which
these roles come and go so just like the
space in this room cannot be destroyed
or created it can be given a shape the
real you is not subject to birth or
death only experiences so are you
referring to reincarnation or you're
saying when we die do we go into another
body rather not use the word
reincarnation I'd use the word recycle
so what recycles is the seeds of memory
and desire and imagination because in
the deeper reality there is no such
thing as a person a person is a process
what's the difference between recycling
and reincarnation and your eyes
reincarnation conjures up this
individual guy who is now you know was
in Iran and now it's reincarnating in
the US or whatever but there's no such
thing as an individual person the person
itself is a process in a non-local
infinite consciousness it's a speck of
God so you're from Iran Rumi said you're
not just a drop in the ocean you're also
the ocean in the drop Rumi the great
Sufi poet course you know
persian poet is there in half Israel
yeah so Rumi says we come spinning out
of nothingness scattering stars like
dust look at these words spinning out of
nothingness this is actually you so you
know create people like Rumi had insight
into the true nature of existence they
didn't get bamboozled by appearances so
again to simplify it the difference
between recycle and reincarnation you
don't want to use the word reincarnation
but it sounds very similar to
reincarnation the seeds of experience
recycle yes
the seeds of experience recycle right is
this why they call some people old souls
because there was very so this old
because it was never born and it's not
subject to death it's infinite it's
timeless I is the timeless factor in
every time bound experience including
the experience that you call your body
your mind because there's no such thing
as a fixed body it's clear you don't
have the same personality you had as a
child right you don't have the same so
am i but am essence in which that
experiences I'm asking these questions
because I want to know your thinking I
want to know your belief so am I decide
early belief in belief belief is a
cover-up for insecurity for us do you
believe in gravity would say that's a
ridiculous question yours you know I'm
certain about this your knowing has to
be experiential and it has to be clear
but to say that to say that means you
are certain about what you're saying yes
I don't I didn t but I could question
you by the way just so you see that it's
fine you know I get it but there's a
difference between saying I believe
because I don't know it all works the
same I know cuz I know it all that's
that's how it would come across
self-knowledge self-awareness realizing
I know a lot of people that are like
that and to have faith and they believe
in a higher power right so I can't say
that person doesn't have self-awareness
or self knowledge or self realization I
think your beliefs can be shaken very
easily
isn't that I made a distinction between
faith and
if so faith is the certainty of the
invisible consciousness without which
there would be no experience of the
visible well I haven't seen that
definition I've seen the faith is
believing in something oh you made it up
that's your that's it that's not
Webster's that's okay in your eyes who
was who was Jesus in your eyes who was
Moses in your eyes who would who was
Muhammad in your eyes like who were
these two you would be carriers in your
eyes people had a religious experience
of what we call spiritual experience
they tried to articulate it and people
didn't understand it because they didn't
have the experience so they created an
ideology around it and then they were
into war okay with each other
have you read the Quran in the Bible yes
okay I've written a book on the life of
the Prophet Muhammad I'd be happy to
give it to you with written a book on
the life of the Buddha and I've written
two books on Jesus you've written two
books on Jesus yes so who's Jesus to you
a messenger so who is who is we live in
a pretty you talk about universe when we
were not we didn't have the camera so
let's go to that because I know that's
something you do want to talk about who
is the creator of this crazy insane out
of this world
you know universe that we live in if
there is no if everybody's God is it a
reality the universe that we called the
universe human it's called the universe
is a human construct let me try and
explain that to you okay
just like you call this couch and this
shirt humans have created the construct
that there is a universe four modes of
knowing and experiencing consciousness
objectively if you look at the universe
right now and the number one question by
the way in science and you don't have to
be
leave me go on the internet and say what
are the open questions science the
number one question in science is what's
the universe made of so why is that an
unknown
well 70% of the universe is something
called dark energy which is expanding
the universe faster than the speed of
light and what's expanding is the space
between galaxies
okay so right now the cosmic horizon is
47 billion light years away from where
we are and galaxies are tumbling across
that there are two trillion galaxies
according to latest estimates there are
760 liyan stars according to latest
estimates there are uncountable
trillions of planets that is less than
4% of the universe 70% is dark energy
26% is another mysterious entity called
dark matter it's invisible because it's
not atomic so we don't know what it's
made of so why do we even call it matter
it's responsible for most of the gravity
in a galaxy so it holds the galaxies
together if there was no dark matter
planets would spiral off and get lost in
intergalactic space so we're left with
4% of the universe which is atomic or
which 99.99%
is invisible interstellar dust probably
hydrogen or helium the visible universe
two trillion galaxies is point zero one
percent and that's all the 706 alien
stars now point zero one percent atomic
atomic but atoms are made of particles
and particles have a dual nature you
know they're particles as material
objects but they're also waves and you
ask people what are these waves made of
they say possibilities so where do these
possibilities exist
they say Hilbert space what is Hilbert
space it's an infinite multi-dimensional
space where is it shut up and calculate
bottom line we don't know what the
universe is made of and the best answer
is is made of nothing
that's the best scientifically accepted
answer so if it's made of nothing why
does it look like this
no one knows that's called the hard
problem of conscious and the challenge
comes back to then how could you be so
certain about what you know not believe
it if I exactly it's the invisible every
time i transcend experience
wouldn't that be everybody do I mean
what's different with you and the rest
of the world they don't take time to be
still do you think you're the only
person that experiences that at that
level no this is all religious all
religious experience is based on I get
it so I to me to me based on what you
just said two trillion is what's visible
and that's point one percent zero one
point zero one percent which means a
thousand times more out there of two
trillion that's if that's the case and
that's how much it's no it's it's not
it's unknown unknown not known and maybe
unknowable because you cannot interact
with something that's not made of at it
what is that right for us to have more
faith it requires you to be bewildered
astonished humbled and reverent I would
agree with that and wouldn't that be to
say that I don't know instead of I know
because to say I know what all those
data that we don't have any idea or in
other words know is that the invisible
is manifesting as the visible that's it
that's faith that's not belief it's a
fact that the invisible is manifesting
is the visible right this moment my
chair I've gone to a lot of churches and
I can tell you the churches that I would
struggle with the most is when the
pastors were hundred percent do you know
what I mean but I'm not saying hundred
yes let me I wasn't really I really want
to hear one to be clear okay cuz you you
I said belief I said what you believe
and he says belief is a sign of
insecurity yeah so so that means if I
say I believe I have some insecurities
which I do
I should have unsecure this because the
universe is two trillion visible point
zero one percent that's a thousand times
unvisible so what you
or no you phrase it okay let me quick
there is no scientific explanation for
existence or awareness of existence so
faith begins with bewilderment
astonishment gratitude humility and
reverence and then it becomes it becomes
concrete when your internal reference
point is not your mind not your body not
anything material but that which is
invisible and you have to be comfortable
with that
the invisible which people call soul
spirit God divine is of Allah Brahman
those are words and you know we have to
use words because we communicate but it
cannot be communicated Rumi against a
gods languages silence everything else
is poor translation therefore if you
want to be certain you have to transcend
into silence yes so for me one when I
study the topic faith what strengthens
fate is the faith is doubt doubt is what
made Martin Luther going I love that
because skepticism is leads ultimately
to fit yes that's the story of my life
you know my I think doubt is whether
it's beautiful the level of curiosity I
wanted to learn you begin with
insecurity and then you ultimately end
up in the certainty of your being which
is beyond cognition perception and
experience which is beyond subject
object split so right now are my
experiences I am the subjective
experience II of the object those are
watching us are subjects of experience
we are the objects but reality is beyond
subject objects Plato
I think we need a part two of this
before we wrap up it did it talk a
little bit about your book the healing
self if you could well this is the
follow-up with Rudy tanzy who's a
geneticist and a neuro geneticist at
Harvard
still right now and we wrote two
previous books super brain and super
genes so super brain was a
neuroplasticity that with your thoughts
and experiences and your choices you can
change the neural networks of your brain
and then super genes was actually about
the fact that you can regulate your
genes as well the microbiome etc so the
healing self goes beyond that looking at
the body as a holistic experience in
consciousness and as an activity of the
total universe so real you and I right
now and everything that's happening is
an activity of the total universe if you
want to call it god that's good I'm
almost certain we're gonna have a part
two with this I don't know when it's
gonna be but I'd like to go a little bit
deeper example think this is Blakey
that's alright no it's not about I I
think believe it or not for me if I had
a university if I ran a university one
then was called Big David University and
you went to it I don't like the way UC
Berkeley does it I don't like the way
Duke does it I don't like the way a lot
of these schools do it and here's what I
mean but I don't like the way they do it
let me let me explain to you what I mean
by that
i I loved opposition I loved it I loved
debate I loved when a person with strong
opinions beliefs or knowings let me say
like this so you're not gonna correct me
and say okay fair enough I'm more on
beliefs but fair enough you would
knowing I want my students to watch that
and based on that the right people to
have a fire in their belly to take the
level of doubt that they don't have to
give birth to curiosity that they go get
for themselves and say I don't know if I
agree with him I don't know if I agree
with them but regardless let me go
research and find out for myself if we
did that our job was well done curiosity
is the most divine experience we can
have in addition to bewilderment
astonishment humility and reference now
let me conclude that everything I've
said I can conclude in one sentence if
you can see it touch it taste it smell
it conceptualize it imagine it think
about it or perceive it it's not
tria what is real is the invisible
without which none of that would be
possible
so the sushi I had last night was not
real nor is the body their transient
experiences in consciousness look they
are certainly bringing a lot of people
that are business and you know I love
talking about business that's my tits
I'm fascinated by it but I also like to
talk to people who have opinions and
beliefs and truths like he does a level
of certainty because that that can give
birth to doing research and topics to
make the arguments even stronger or to
find the kinks in an argument to have to
make your own adjustments and pivots
again to be more childlike and want to
learn even more battle if you're
watching this and and you you you got
something from it or you have a question
or something in your mind I want you to
tweet at dr. Deepak Chopra what is your
Twitter handle by the way at the punch
of it so there's no doctor in front it's
just Deepak Chopra if you can send a
tweet but you add Deepak Chopra your
takeaway question whatever you may have
and who knows you may get a response
okay so send the tweet to him at Deepak
Chopra and then obviously if what he
talked about interests you you got one
of 88 books to choose from just go on
Amazon type and Deepak Yosemite will pop
up obviously this is the most recent one
that just came out dr. Chopra thank you
so much for making the time I really
enjoy the truly appreciated